You
Hi everybody, sorry, I'm late. I literally just loaded in and I'm eating cold pasta
Hi
You guys want to introduce yourselves, although they all know you, but you want to introduce yourselves again
Okay, I'm going first
Thank you so much
We want feet pics her to up boys, all right, you know what to do
Okay, next is the alphabet
That's it, we'll be married and it's nice. No locked in to dress to impress right now
Introduce yourself
I'm supposed to be the pink cat girl
But now I'm like an army like world miles away something else. I'm like an army cat now
I'm also in my feet journey of chai. We're locked in literally toes into a lock sweating together
In this foot in this foot world that we call
Bicubing um, you know me. I'm in cb's cat a lot a lot
Uh, and I love cb too
I love and I'm typing chat because you guys know you guys should know who I am
Hi, I'm Toma keys. I am a liminal space monkey and I also
Frequent cb's chat, but whenever we come over to play I send a dog instead
Yeah, the dog usually hangs out
Yeah, but today you get me the silly little monkey and my hand puppet
And hi
If you don't know me
Which you do because you're on my channel
But if you're on the other girls channels because they're streaming right now too their links are in my description
um
I'm shibi cotton bum of gen ones
Viewers gen one indulge. I can never talk and say that it's a tongue twister
I swear to god and I'm your favorite girl failure dom and I'm very tired and I've been cleaning
In my tummy hort, but we're here
If you hired me I clean your house for free because you know I'm Hispanic that's like in my board. I got you
I'll clean for you
Why do you have a binky by the way? Where did that come from?
Um, I just need it right now. Okay. So you need something to suck on
Yeah, because I can't suck on your
I'm scared of that girl. I'm so scared of her. I'm drinking gamer sups. I'm
I'm drinking about the energy
I got orange juice
Now I have I have I grabbed the wrong soda
I'm drinking a disgusting Pepsi right now. Like it's absolutely horrid, but it's fine
How do I play uh, are you okay? Wait
Oh my god, wait coach
Use coach eebie
Use coach eebie me who's never drink gamer sups. Yeah use coach eebie
Use coach eebie free worldwide shipping until the 13th
Really?
Yeah, I'm on I'm on the anime girl the anime girl thigh
Tub guys get my thighs. That's so incredible. I never got to say congratulations. Thank you
It's crazy. It's it's truly an honor
Yes to have your thighs for the whole world to see. Yeah
My my very pale thighs my intense thighs
It's okay. They'll get the seasoned ones next time. Yeah next time
She be where are you jumping the game press your space board?
Okay, follow me ladies
To the tanning booth this way
Here are your come here. Do I have to collect money?
No, you don't yet. No, how do I train ever?
Totally right here how to change the freaking angle of stuff. How do I change the camera angle?
Oh, oh, I figured it out. Okay. Come here. This is the tanning booth. You can be black white little white girl
They added so much the theme is shopping
Yeah, the theme is shopping. Well, I'll be I'll be a little chocolatey woman. Um
I'll be right back. I'm just gonna say hi to my chat and then I'm gonna come back. How do I get out of here?
You want to like just press jump jump or space? Oh, okay. Okay. Come here. Here's the nail tech. It's not the original
It's a fake. There's lord of the skin by this way. Where did you go this way? I'm jumping
Am I in front of you people jumping? No, there is not. I'm literally right here
Irma what the sigma?
Okay, come here. Look, look, look
So this is where you can change your nails
There's more to this game. By the way, this is a fake lady. I can do under the basement
What?
Do you want to go to the basement?
Right now
I'm gonna do yellow nails
Only if you want to you can go to the basement if you want to
I don't I just want to know where to get the clothes in my face. Where the heck do I get a face?
Okay, uh, literally in that same room with the nails you go to this literal makeup station right here. Okay
Yep. Yep. Yep. Oh queen
Yeah, so you can have a bunch of faces. Uh, the left is custom faces. They have to pay wait
I can see myself behind you on your street
Wait the custom faces I have to pay for
Yeah, okay, so I do the right faces
Yeah, the right
Yes, this game has lor this game has lor so lana is like a clone
So the lady the nail tech that you guys can saw that's not the real like for nail tech
She's in the basement. I can take you to the basement
Do you want to go to the basement? I can get myself up
Oh
Ayo
Let me know if you want to go to the basement
I'll go to the basement with you. Give me a second. I'm trying to I'm trying to find the look
Hey, where's the first face I had? I actually like that. That's very cute. Very kawaii desu. How do I get out? Okay. I'm
Help
Game
Uh, where do I get clothes? Oh, no over the basement. Let's go to the basement. We have 40 seconds
I couldn't even do this this thing
These are where you get jeans like jeans
Get the pay for these items. Okay, uh free free wall
Free wall
How do I how do I put stuff on it? Just put it on right in front of you. We hover over it
You just click on it. Yeah, you just click on it and there's a patterns wheels things like that. Where are shoes?
Oh, the shoes are um over here
Right here. How do you move so fast? I bought the walking thing
I paid to walk fast
Wait, no, I wanted I wanted to put on a cowgirl hat
Pop smoke
That's pop smoke. I told you
I like it pop smoke kind of it's it's it's it's it's okay. I don't really
I I didn't do anything. I didn't click anything. That's kind of why I didn't try move all the way over there
She's she's because she's doing something. I think
But how did she move she shouldn't be able to
I don't like this one because this looks like Gucci like
Oh, then we all just get disconnected. Yeah, I think that's why
I
That's not even shopping. She's in a wedding dress. She's not shopping one
Hello, kitty is swearing. I don't even know what that says
Uh
I don't know what's happening
No, I hit my mic. I'm sorry. Oh, do you guys?
Oh
I know you bump
Five stars see if you on the right you can pose on the right you can pose. Yeah
What a joker moment
Guess what mean question
Oh, actually queen. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Five stars. That's my outfit five stars
My game crash on money. I can't pose but that's my outfit guys
Man, I lost my entire outfit
Who are these why are there two of them? Oh, you can double up. Oh, that's cool. Uh, you guys are kind of basic
So you're gonna get a one. Hi. Yeah
Honestly, I have a bad habit of giving everyone five stars
You're so sweet, Toma
Toma, Toma, you're the mannequin. That's so smart. You're the mannequin of the dress. Oh, I get it. Oh, it's a shopping theme
I know you didn't I don't think I gave you five stars. Toma. I gave you five stars. You're like slay mannequin slay
It's because they knew they got the mannequin
That makes no sense. You got to say slay queens. Thanks. So you don't look like like a b-word. You got to speak the language
It goes like
slay queen
Yeah, slay queen. Thanks. All right. Um, how do I take off my clothes?
Uh, you click on the head and glasses and then you just hit the egg
I mean, I would take them off for you anytime
You're the stupid child
How do we are we gonna oh change your walk speed?
Also, I don't know why my game keeps crashing. So it kind of sucks
I just get to like make the outfit and then it crashes. What are these people doing?
Uh, platforming, I guess
No, this is a platformer
I didn't either until just now
Excited, I'm so thankful to be able to have this opportunity to play with you guys and to play dressed for the press
Me too. Thank you. My gift is again
How do I take off my skin?
You can't
I am stuck being a black woman
I mean
Isn't that just life though?
That's this IRL
You know, I can't see
Oh
All right, uh, let's do oh, I have an idea. I have an idea
You guys have VIP. I really want to buy it because I want to wait
Yeah, no, I don't I don't have I don't have VIP. That's that'd be I was how I don't have money. Where's the free wall?
I do
I want it so I could slay
Okay. Oh my god. I
Yeah
Tie right. Yeah
I'm ready. I'm just throwing random. Wait. What the fuck. I can't buy it for you yet
Oh, no, I wanted to be pinkie pie. Where's the hair? I was gonna gift it for you in the in the middle place
I found it in the saloon
Maybe that sucks
Let's do do I have like really crazy curly hair
Wait, I'm really excited to slay. I've never slayed before. I don't I bet I didn't always say you're gonna look beautiful because I love you
But you always slay tie
It looks like cotton candy
I'm wearing two hairs. Did it crash? Yeah, I don't know why he keeps crashing. It's never done it this much before
I got to play yesterday for an hour before my game like broke man in that a statement. I need it
I'm gonna be
I have I'm gonna be black
You're gonna be black
Why'd you go black? You never go back
Just saying
The darker the berry the sweeter the juice they say
What does that mean? The darker the berry the sweeter the juice. Well, you see when you go down on a black lady
What about like black strawberries like dark strawberries those are sweet dark strawberries. I can't find any shoes in this place
Okay, wait, let me try to make my outfit really quick. I'm wearing sneakers
This is not going with the fit
I'm stupid
I don't know what I'm doing
I wish I had a wizards cap
I'm not slaying
This is not a slaying. You are slaying queen. You will slay
I look like a combination of rarity and pinkie pie. Is there like balloons? Where's the there is but they're in a
VIP VIP
Stupid
Why is it when I look like Cleopatra?
What are their fits do we got honestly? I like what I'm wearing. Can I get some earrings?
Ooh earrings queen. Yes, we'll do them. We'll do them in gold
What is this
This girl's wearing the same outfit
Get the fuck out. I bet you are slaying and you're just
Hating. I can't I'm trying to find chai
She's like crying in the cleaner
I'm not gonna change my dress because this girl's coffee
I'm about I'm about to foogie. Oh you look cute. What are you talking about?
Oh, it's not a scene but you are slaying. I will tell you that one
I'm hearing a lot of crying and not a lot of sashaying right now
Well, I was sashaying but I got disconnected
Yeah, I don't want to put the money in me for like
Five five seconds. It's good. I'm a birthday bunny
You know, maybe maybe I just can't play roblox and hoes v2 studio at the same time impressive. Oh, maybe
That sucks this game
Might as good crashing. I'm just really scared that I hope I don't crash
Oh, actually, you know every collab needs a little scuff
Yeah, every collab needs a little scuff. Yeah, don't worry
This bitch this bitch
Fuck you. I look so much cuter than you
You think he's copying you?
She's literally following me around
Wait, who is
Maybe he comes one girl. Do you want me to bark at her? I got you. I've received a go
Stop it. Stop it. I'll be getting accessories. Oh, what's that?
You have to buy that it's
Which ones these are free. These are all free and there's like little secret items sometimes that you can find
Okay, I'm changing my dress because fuck that girl
Actually, no, I mean dress back because that dress looks better. I just realized you have to walk back to get it
Yeah, you know the key is to layer and pattern
How do you pattern today? I'm gonna learn on slay. It's on the in the color wheels
Oh, I can do brat. Oh, I just fell over and died
Wait, where did everybody go?
I just realized that no one's there
How honestly, this is oh, I kind of like it
Oh, it's like like uh, like uh, what's it? It might be like a black banana like a black. Oh
In the club young intern, let's go pop smoke
I don't know
Can african
I'm looting guys everyone
I gave you five stars child. I like it black child black child from africa
No, I like it. No
Are we
Pigs get a buddy ears at a birthday. Yeah her friend immediately
Wait, I could try I could try to host
Yeah, maybe someone else should host. I'll try to horse again. This batch dog my outfit
Two stars. I should I should I should I'm giving her one star
I should have kept the dress on because I look so much better than her
I think if you give them three stars though, it'll add up to like a thing which is really stupid. Okay
um
I made the room. What is that? The pass rate is the same
Okay, like a simple. Yes. I know the girls models are gone
Yeah, yeah, we had the same dress and I changed my dress last second guys
Yes, you did. You didn't see it. Tisk tisk tisk. I was there for it all. Wait, who's hosting?
Me me me. I'm hosting you're hosting. Okay. Oh, okay. I like this is like high school
Like, you know, like the girls when they have the crowns and the balloons in school
Very cute. Is that just me because I go to like I can't vote because I am trying to do this
All right, same password
Yes, same password
Okay, it might just take us a while to load in so please don't
Close it. Oh, this is cute
simple
Simple birthday party. You can't go wrong with a black dress
I'm gonna say a black one
Yeah, maybe it wasn't before you changed you everybody shut up. It was the same outfit
Damn, why are you so good at this though? I'm gonna learn. I'm gonna be just like you slay
Snapping my fingers. Oh, I can't I'm not guys guys. That's the first time I've been crashing a while
Yes
You're so good, I knew you could do it
Wait, I'm gonna force I'm gonna force myself on for this podium. Yeah, no, I don't think models are gonna
She be I don't think models are gonna work this this no. Yeah, I'm gonna do Fuji tech. We're doing Fuji tech guys
Yeah
Okay, wait mines is
I can curse, right? Yes, you can curse. My Fuji's fucked up. So give me something. Let me fix it
Okay, give me I think it's a bold black mexican guy. I don't know. I don't know
I can't roll blocks on my super pc
Yeah, my roblox crashed here again. Fucking
How do we go? No, no, everything's running fine. It's just the closing vtube studio. Yeah vtube studio is struggling
Yeah, oh wait, so it's not just you. It's it's not uh, just I think you're just gonna turn off. I think I'm gonna not use vtube studio
This is kind of getting annoying. Oh, okay. That's reassuring because I was so confused of why it was so being so laggy
This is another reason why we were late guys because we were trying to figure out figure that out
Oh, is vtube studio theme is happy
Yeah, I don't know vtube studio just keeps breaking for me. It's like getting me very
All right, I have an idea
I need where's the skin tone?
Oh, yeah, everything just instantly improved the moment I closed vtube studio. I'm so grateful. Oh cool. Okay
I have to use my discord icon. I don't have anything right now
Oh
Wait, I know I know where's the tanning booth? Where's the tanning salon? There it is
Why can't I click a pattern for my skin tone?
Okay
There's the color wheel. Let's do this again chat or we know
I'm gonna be
Also, I'm sorry for being yellow. It's so funny
Sorry for being really annoying and loud. Please forgive me
Okay, it's fine. Just don't do it next time
You're so right. I should get can you hit me now?
Can you wag me on my head? I know what I'm gonna do. I have an idea
And I don't think I can act it out
I'm trying to be spongebob
Oh my gosh, sheebie. You're you're a boogie. Wait the tola the tola draw it. Yeah, I'm a muppet. What's this?
I love it. That's so cute. I love it so much. This person also has the same idea as me
Okay, any
Sunglasses put on some
How do I make brown?
Uh, well, you see the way that you make brown is you eat food and eventually science
I don't know
What what do you want? I'm telling you exactly I'm like sheebie
Where I'm trying to oh actually this will work because it'll try
I don't know. I I is there a tie
Yes, I found it. I found the tie. I was like, I don't know where the what color is spongebob's tie
I
Wait, can I add patterns? I need to add a pattern to my skin
I don't think you can add patterns. Oh, I glitched it glitched out. That's how that's why
Okay, let me bra
I'm very proud of myself right now
Uh, what does she wear?
Uh, I need I need some clothes. I need some shoes
I can never find the right shoes
Okay, I'll just
It's okay. Chai
Okay, you're fine. You're okay. You're fine. Chai. I'm learning
Chai, just have fun with it. Just have fun with it. Do you want to help getting up though?
Why is Chai a dog? She's not a dog. She's just dog posing
Chai to get back up. Just click on the poses again and then like just click on the pose and then unclick it
And then I'll let you like stand up
Oh, thank you
Okay, what's in the basement? No, because I just okay. Let's wait. Let's go to the basement. Let me put on some shorts
Let's go to the basement
Wait, I need I need hold on hold on. I need I need I need
I need
Oh, where are they there they are
Okay, you want to go to the basement? Yes
Okay, come to the nail salon
I come to the nail. I needed I needed like little thigh highs. I'm standing in front of it
Come to the nail salon. I'm jumping. Okay
I'm right in front of you. I'm spongebob. Hi
Come in here. Hi spongebob. I'm patrick
Wait, this game is gonna teach me how to be creative
Wait, you didn't follow me. Oh my god, look at spongebob. Hold on. Let me change my face real quick
I
Are you right up on me? I need blue eyes
I can smell you. Oh, perfect. You smell lovely. Okay. I'm ready to go
Okay, come come come here. Ready? Ready? Ready? Yeah, what's the basement? What time are you?
Holy time over here. I'm jumping. Why is she in a cave? Come here. Come here. Come here. Ready? Ready?
Uh-huh. Come inside
Oh
Bros. Yeah, this is the real nail tech. There's laura. I told you
What is the nail tech?
Where is she? Her name is like mine, but she's so different nails. Please believe I'm real. She'll be gone
What the how do we get out of here? Oh, there's a ladder
This is so crazy. I'm gonna change my shoes. Yeah. Yeah, wait, wait
So
Oh, wait, I just distracted you times. I'm sorry
but in the game there's like
Profile codes that you can go on to people's pro like in the character's profiles
And find them so it's like horror game stuff and there's a game where she like tries to chase you like a bunch of them
And before around the map there was like a bunch of lanas like the old lady that's in the caves
They're like she would like spawn around the map
So yeah
For that is the lore. What is this? Uh, basic bitches
White women
I mean, I guess I guess you can't be happier than that. They're like a cute lesbian couple and that's why they're happy. I don't know
They look kind of they look kind of pouty. I have no idea what I said. I'm sorry. Oh my god. It's yuji itadori from yuji tukaisu
Oh
Actually, I'll give you a floor for that just because I think he lives because just because it's it's itadori
Oh, yeah, I guess he I don't know. I've never seen yuji tukai jinn. It's really gourd
Five stars
I give you four stars because you're like kind of naked
But your feet are out. So that's like that's what gave you four. I gave her five stars for feet. I love your feet
Ty, I want to like rub our feet together. Oh my god
Okay, this is
Bunch bombs totally happy
I say I'm ready
I'm ready. I'm ready. I'm ready
Oh god, could you imagine could you imagine spongebob in the bedroom? I'm
Oh, I can't even do it. I love it
angle just break
Oh, that's pretty cute. I'll give you a floor for that
Okay, I'll be I like it. It's a very easy one stars because the pink is kind of out of place in my opinion
So I'm being technical
Oh
Oh, no, I'm little miss sunshine
I like it very cute
Feet collab if she wants to absolutely because oh it's joy from inside out
I'm not gonna lie. I'll give her you know, I'll get I like I like it. I'll give her five
I'm gonna type very
Yeah, I think she tried she had creativity. I like I like that one girl who just did green hair
Oh, Chai you're fine
Oh my gosh, you guys are so cool
Ty, you're gonna really
Ty, you're really gonna get like
It's so good at this game. I better get Lee second place
Yeah, I'm gonna do it. I think you are
Oh
Wait wait post 28 post 28 post 28
Wait, Chai Chai Chai you're in front of chibi. It's at the very bottom. It's like post 28. Just
Yeah, post 28
Oh, I have post 12
Wait, dude post 28
Yeah, what are you doing down there, Chai?
I really like the dog
Oh, yeah, post 28
All right time to get this stuff off so we're ready for next round facts
I don't know how much I would enjoy this
Wait, I can tell you're like
I can tell you're my level
My level is
I can walk around like this
Yeah, you can
Let's see how
I really like this game Chai. So if you ever want to play it, just ping me and I'll drop everything
Oh, I have an idea
Sorry. Oh my god. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I think Mari might win this one. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my side
Can I please get out of this pose?
Just click it again
Latina
No, I can be Latina
You were always Latina in my eyes
Thank you. Okay, my team studio is making me upset at a bit of rage
I just closed out of it. It was just crashing too much. I think it was breaking my road box
Stupid
It's so stupid. I know how it's supposed to be creative if you can't
I can't
Sure. No, I don't I don't like if you guys watch too hot to handle
What is that?
I have never watched it before
But I know it would be right up my alley
Wait, what is that?
It's a that like original like reality show
Uh and it's about like these really hot people that go on
and they
Oh are like really horny
But they're not allowed to kiss each other or touch each other
And if they kiss or touch each other then
There's like a prize pool like at the end that they can win
But if anyone kisses or touches each other then it takes money out of the prize pool
But because they're so horny they like can't resist
each other
And like you kind of just watch people suffer I guess
I'm gonna ask in like a nice way
I think I gave it really bad this good
No, no, that was like
I just loved how you were talking about it because you're just like I'm sure of yourself
I thought you were explaining it
It's very cute
I just I'm just so
People watch shows like that. Yeah, that's why I love love island
Dude, I watch like love island blilly and like like kid cartoons. I'm watching paul patrol. No, that's like my thing right now
It's paul patrol
I have too much hair on
There's a hot little bit on it right now. So I'm inspired
But I also love blilly
I love lily
Blur is great. You guys should watch uh paul patrol
No, I'm not gonna I watch the paul patrol movies and that's as far as I'm taking that
What the fuck
The movie is good
I'm not gonna watch the show because it's got a cop dog named chase in it. I ain't I ain't about that. That's actually pretty
Actually, actually the the cop dog is like the least favorite. No one likes the cop dog
That's what they push him the most because he has the least sales
Yeah, because he's the worst
Yeah, he sucks. I don't like it either
Like he was the main character for the first movie and I don't understand why they decided to do that
Really?
But luckily they they they changed their ways for the second movie. Thank thank god
Fuckin
I wonder if you and chai will become muppets
Um
I'd like to be a muppet that sounds like a fun hobby. I like the muppet movie a lot
I love the muppet movie. Which one?
uh
Like the muppet movie the new one that came out with walter
Yeah, yeah, and he's like I have a meh
I'm a muppet. What the hell? I like that song speaks to me a lot
Let's see. What else do I want?
Hmm, I feel like I'm needing something else. Oh, I'll tell you probably
Oh, hell, yeah, I messed up my hair, but it's fine. I don't really care that much
I wish I had vip actually
I wanted to gift you and trust me. I was literally going to do that
and then I was gonna like
Teach you and vip very I can help you. I find a better dress
Wait, why are you?
I think you're doing a nice
Actually just a layer. I like the colors
I don't like
My color. We're fashion-y staying. Don't worry. Don't worry
But yeah, I really oh
Chase is the least favorite because he's just not as like markable because like cop toys are kind of like boring to kids so like
Compared to like a lot of kids like favorite toys are like dump trucks and like
Like construction toys are a lot cooler. Oh wait, is there like a fan? They can pick up dirt and stuff
So that's why I would I would love like a fans or something
There's a fan, but it's in the uh
It's in the IP
Oh
No, wait, I'm trying to see why can't I get I'm gonna see if I can give someone the IP
Why can't I get people?
Okay, wait, I can at the buy it and then I can gift it
Okay, oh really? I'm kind of slaying. So I'm so locked in
Here try
Thank you. Thank you so much. Who wants VIP? She'd be your tommorow. Please. I already have it. Please. I already have VIP
Somebody already gifted it to me
Okay, I just it's for a month so it expires. You like Muppets Christmas Carol someone see I was gonna do red like that
Oh my god. Yes. Muppets Christmas Carol is good. I like the one with the blue bird guy
Pop smoke just be slaying
And you mean sam easel
No, I'm gonzo. Yeah, I have a crush on gonzo. What you have a crush on gonzo?
Well to be fair, gonzo fucks chicken. So you might okay, baby. I'm learning
Okay, I'm learning except for I like that's pretty good
I feel like chi is gonna steal my twin husband. This is my twin husband
Well, tell a novella tell a novella's always have like some weird plots like I'm here to steal your husband
But it's not really my husband. It's his twin brother. Horatio
Oh my god. They look like a donna. Oh my gosh. I don't know what that means
It's a good thing. It's a good thing. It's like a bad
Me and old bitch
I'm sorry, this is pelvic thrusting away is so fun. Oh, she's probably ready. Oh my god
I I see it
It's very la fea. It's my favorite show
I think I always do whenever outfits whenever I get this thing. I just love it so much
I think if I don't win this it's actually racism against me as a hispanic
Oh my god, five stars
She's trying to seduce me with divorce papers to divorce my life. Literally. My god. She can get my inheritance from my abuela
It's just spun away
I want her to touch me
Who's wee-wee?
Well, to be fair simple is best
Tell them I don't know that are you kidding me?
I look like I'm here to steal your husband's
Inheritance
Who is that supposed to be? I don't know. This is definitely a reference. I'm a marie
Yeah, yeah, it's it's a reference. I don't I'll give you a three. I like the reference. It's just because it's the male face on the female body, I think
Oh, is she also supposed to be ugly baddie? I guess I think mine's just better. Yeah yours is better. I'm gonna give her a two for effort
Ugly bd2 part perdon
Okay, that's it that makes you a little bit
It really oh
She looks like a rap girl. I'm gonna give you a four for that. She kind of looks like she'd like
Tell me like so hot goss
To ruin America. It looks like that's wait. It's the it's the young it's the young woman that like takes your husband
What the young sexy secretary
Sorry
It makes me blush and turns me on a little bit. Thank you. This feels like a spanish server
It's either just the team or everyone in this server happens to conveniently speak
Haha, no pass another is
How did that? Yeah, I don't I don't know how none of the baddies won
Is is really nutty a telenovela. So it was originally a telenovela and then they made it an english version
Oh, like the office was british before they made an american version
Yeah, though spanish version is way better because she actually kind of looks in my opinion a little unattractive
But the action is very beautiful. Do I just want to keep playing this or do you want to play um
scary game now
Oh, we can
Can we play some more because we just got vip
It's like one more
Oh, they gave your berp a 10 out of 10 toma
I know i'm impressive. Yeah guys. I was not
What is it? What's the theme?
I vip now
Myself, where is it? I'm cosplaying myself. Give me those shoes
All right, I know what I want. Oh wait. No, I'm going. I know exactly where to go
Uh, I'm gonna stay
I'm literally this is perfect. I'm cosplaying as myself. Uh, let's do
Ew, ew, ew, can I please just get like normal blonde?
Okay, uh, figure it out. You know, I think I'll do
I know who I'm gonna do but it's probably very
Meish what I want to do
Actually, I don't like issues bo b so they call a new ball, you know, okay, this isn't quite me
I
Need to change my face
Are you holding up their chai
I'm learning. I'm learning. I'm doing it. I'm proud of you fixing. Uh, what's it called?
I'm like a baby cat who's just got their leg. Uh, they just learned how to stand
Oh
You're my favorite. I'm in vip. I'm in vip. What does this mean?
Oh, it's 11 11
Make a wish
I want cb to come blast me with her fingers in my butt. Okay, that's my wish
That's that's my wish. That's my wish. Go go go for your dream. I guess
You can do it if you believe
Yay
Oh, I don't need that. What is this?
Um, I think I'm in a blue
Oh, wait, what's that? Oh, yeah, that's a beautiful
And then I'm gonna change my skin tone
I need to change the top of my outfit and it's not working me and this girl the same skirt
Me and we we have the same skirt. Um, I need it. I'm gonna let's see here
Oh, I like I mean those baby doll heels
One step at a time
Actually let me change the top
What top is she wearing?
No, that's not it actually this
I'm so locked in I need to have we're all locked in and yeah, I know it's so quiet
Oh, actually I'm kind of feeling this can I like relayer this belt?
Is this a watch? No, that's a brace. I don't
I
Feel like what I'm referencing is very obscure
I wish I could change where something is
Yeah, that's fine
Where did the top that I had go I don't know I preferred that well, it's up top. There you go. Yep
Hmm
Feeling real basic feeling real under the sign
Where are you? Oh my god
I need to take off this. Oh, I have 55 seconds. This is gonna be my worst showing yet
Told me I like nice
Thank you. I wish I could walk faster. Where's the skirt? I need skirt. I need a four I need a skirt in 45 seconds
Oh wait
Where's chai trying to find chai chai you look so cute
Thank you
I like trying to match the color. Oh, the bow the hair is really pretty too. It's more of like a
I'm just gonna do like socks or leggings. Uh, yeah, there is come here this way this way over here over here
Tight on the right and then leggings on the oh perfect. Can I get like a laptop?
Oh, you can use books
There's books in the game. That's like kind of it. Where are books? Oh, no
Oh
Oh, I wanted the box she looks cute pop smoke
I I'll give her a three. I gave her a three
I don't like the tie
Because there's a top that you can make it like
Have you guys ever seen the movie secretary?
No
Tiger movie is really big for sale. I'm good
Do you know what the movie secretary is about? Let me know. What is it about the mixer?
Oh, man, okay
Very serious business. Oh, what is this secretary movie about?
It's about a woman who's a neat who gets a job to be this guy's secretary and he's got like
Pose why can't I pose?
Oh, it's like, oh, it's supposed to be she me. Oh my gosh. You kind of look like isabel
And it turns out she accidentally gets into a btsm relationship with her boss
What? Oh, okay
Wait, oh, let me get past so final fuck final destination. She's a secretary
Oh
Thank you
I like it. I don't know. I tried to to make references
Yeah, but what so that's what the movie secretary's about. Why are you a cool alpha woman?
Yeah, what what is this reference thing?
Yeah, I'm just a helper. I'm a helper elf
It's a key blur elf
I'm a key blur elf
What's a key blur, sorry
Oh, man, this really good. Wee wee looks like she's a bitch on a bit on a mission
Yeah, like the meta the bitchy secretary at like the pop-up office
Um, I asked for an ice chai. This is a lukewarm chai
What the fuck are you doing?
Why is chai lukewarm?
I like this
Oh the chai, why is this one?
I'll give her a five
I like the little side neck thingy
Yeah
What was this?
There's the secretary left no crumbs. There's two in on wires
Oh, oh sugar butter
And I like this one. I saw her's really pretty
This looks like secretary like photo shoot
Like you just this is like a like a boy secretary
Ma'am, I need you to get your skirt down to your knees. I can almost see your pussy pop
No, it's supposed to be like that
No, your secretary's not supposed to be popping her pussy. Your secretary's not supposed to be popping your her pussy
How's she supposed to get work done?
She pops her pussy on my desk at work. So yeah
What no, I don't want pussy juice all over my important documents
I do
No, look, it's you
That's not to push me because my name is margie l marie
Oh
Damn, I don't like I don't like the the contour. I don't like the lips. The lips are like booty hole lips
Also cracker. I don't leave my house enough to worry about dying till a truck. So no
All right, none of those. Okay. That's all right
The pussy pop
I don't think it's right. I like one more. Can we play like one more please? Yes
I need to redeem myself after that one. That one was bad. Are you gonna roll?
No, I thought you're just so good. You're a sheebie
No, I wasn't a good sheebie because I lose I really just threw stuff together
But you are a sheebie
No, no, you are sheebie
Yeah, yeah, I know the log truck scene, but I don't leave my house to like
Wait like to fear about that. My fear is elevators like just dropping my drop to my death
I could do a split. Oh my god
Come out to the beach. You guys want to play on the beach with me?
Oh my god, wait, can we make sand castles? Where's the beach?
Where are you?
I'm playing with the poses
Hi
Hi, we're doing our toes together child. I like how I'm permanently like walking on my tiptoes
Oh
Okay, okay, okay, okay. I need to think I don't think I got a chance the weeps have a chance
Oh, okay. Oh frick. Okay. Who can I?
Okay, I'm I have an idea
Okay, wait
I know exactly who I'm going to do. I don't know
Wait, I need a picture reference. I need a picture reference
There's so many things you can do that's the problem
I think I I know who I'm gonna do
I don't think they'll have what I need to do this one
Now frick
Oh my gosh, I'm doing it and I would know what's gonna. No, but I'm doing it. No, I'm not gonna be able to do mine. I'm wasting time
I
Okay, I'm switching. I'm gonna switch. I'm gonna switch. I have a different idea. It'll it'll be fine
I was gonna do kasame
But it didn't work out
You could do it. You could do anything. No, I well, I can't I couldn't find like a big jacket for the akatsuki robe
Oh, I think I don't you have VIP. I feel like you can make anything happen with VIP. No
Instead I'm going to be
I know what I'm gonna do
Wait, you all want to say or you want to surprise each other? I think we're gonna go surprises surprise each other. Okay
Okay
I don't have to pay money. I thought it had to be a payment
For some things you still have to pay. It's like a grind like you grind for items. That's like the
This sucky thing about it. I'm sorry
What else? Oh, I also need a photo reference
Yeah, actually
Don't prick them on typing
Yeah
Chad I feel like you should know what I okay. That's fine. That's perfect. Actually. It's very simple very straightforward
Um, how do you hit you can't be put on is because it's male. Yeah. Do I need to change my body?
You can
Oh frick, okay
Oh no, I'm wasting so much freaking time
Oh
What the
Wait, no, then I only have like two hairstyles
Oh my god
Guys, I'm blowing it
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, you can still do it. You can still do it. You can still do it
I'm trying. I believe in you. Oh my god, please. I wish I could walk just a little bit faster
Oh
Wait, are those if you can't call it color toggle
Take those boots
Can't
This actually works better it's not the same
Hold on coffee coffee coffee
Okay
What get off the wall
Is there a tie
Yes, so yes, so I always I'm trying to look at my finger, you know
I'm trying to see if I'm doing it right my bad. Yeah, there's a tie. There should be ties
Um
Are there like jackets
Yes, but I you have VIP so there should be there
Time I need the patterns to load
But time is over here. Right here. I'm jumping. I'm jumping. I'm jumping on where you are
I'm outside of the IP just another tanning boots. Oh, I see you. I see you
Wait, where are the jackets?
Outside of the tanning boots
Yeah, like right. Oh wait the tie. She said right
Are you like you got me?
All right, I'm just gonna use this one because I don't wait. Where are the jackets?
Where are the jackets? I think this way. I think this way. I think this way disconnected
No
No, my country
What?
I hate everything I hate it
I was gonna serve so good as Shrek
I'm not there. Maybe you were gonna be too powerful
Wait, is there no jacket? I was gonna be the best Shrek
I don't think anybody's gonna get this
I don't even look I usually like the character
Oh, are you held this in Claire from Atlantis?
Wait, so what are you? I did my hair wrong
I'm the main character. Oh, it's light yagami
It's light yagami, what are you talking about clearly light yagami
Who is it?
Oh wait should be for you. I've got it. I'm gonna say nice light in chat
I'm Edward Ulrich
You're typing in the chat. They might not know
You're Elsa
I love Elsa
Of course you're fucking soccer
It's I'm helping you
I'm just kidding. It wasn't light yagami. It was a gender met version
Yeah, she's just coping now coping
Come on
What the fuck is that? Is this a
Oh
Double McRae?
Gojo, that's a gojo. That looks more like Dante
Is this my gojo?
It looks more like Dante
I mean, yeah, this looks like Dante, like what?
That looks like Dante
Oh, lol, I mean, buddy
I can't believe it. That's pretty good. This person definitely plays like every single day of their life
It's not fair. I had a good
It's not fair
I had a good trip
If we ever want we can just make up our own theme and then we can just dress up however we want
Wait, is this the girl from avatar? Oh avatar. Yeah, well a bit of lego
I don't know why they didn't just do the pattern skin. I remember when I was little
I thought people with little lego had like a skin disease
So I didn't want to touch them because I got scared that I would get it to
I've never met anyone in person. Oh my god. Oh my god. At least at least marie, please
Yeah
Or do you want to go to the next game?
I'm kind of mad at dress for impress honestly. I had a really good country track
I saw you dressing up green. I was wondering what you were going with
I was going for cunty track. Okay. What's the spooky thing you said?
Um, we could play doors doors
Yeah, I watch a more video about doors, but I totally forget what it's about
We could play doors. Do you want to play doors? I've beaten doors before. I'm very good at it
Now we need to play doors. Okay, uh
I got to door 91 before I died so that made me really sad. I want to play more dress to impress later
I didn't know this would be so fun. Okay, everyone's going back on. It's very exciting. We can play after three. Yeah
Yeah, we can. I don't mind. Wait, my face is all fucked up in the game. So just um, I'm jumping steeby
Yes, I said hi to the yay
I'm jumping up. I didn't know that she raided. I feel bad
Let's see. I only saw her in chat and I hot girl wrenched her
You hot girl wrenched her? Yeah. Yeah, we're playing doors. No
Oh, yeah, vc mute your vc. Uh, your vc by the way
People are talking in the game. Why do I?
What did you
All right, here's she be how do I mute people escape and then at the very top mute all
I look terrifying. Why are you so cute and small? Why do I look like this?
Wait, wait type in the game. She'd be typing the game really quick
Just slash something in game
I said they are on they are off. Well, there's tons of people
Nah, I'm sigma
I know my big sign above my head. It took it off of you. It strips you
Wait, I don't see sound controls at all
Can I please I look horrifying. How do I how do I become small like you?
You have to buy it. What? Wait, look at me though. Look at me though. You look very cute too. Try what the hell
What the fuck my head didn't load heading it. Why do you have little why do you have monster feet?
I'm shaking my butt
There you are
You
Really inappropriate about your robux avatar
I have like
Say it say it to my face. I want to I want to do disgusting things to like if I was a guy
I would grab you by the neck and just start pounding into you. Oh your face is every passing week
And then I would take you to dinner at your favorite restaurant. I would treat you very nicely
Take me to dinner before you treat me like an ono hole, please. Okay. Yeah priorities
Priorities, I'm gonna make the the lobby guys. So tall friends only one two. Wait. How much how many are there?
Oh, thank god, there's only four
Okay, you guys should be able to join me join me quick in the wait in elevator 29 elevator 29. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
At the bottom right there should be a thing where you can join me like friends
Oh guys
Okay
So how do you play this because I would teach you some things so
Um, I'm gonna give you guys like the sound cues because I know for like the first two times
It's really hard. So there's a monster called rush and what he will do is he will essentially
Yeah rush you the flights will flicker and you'll hear like
The lights will switch to flicker. Once the lights flicker
um
You have to hide into a closet. So if you don't hide in a closet in time you die
I don't I don't think I I don't
uh, but
Oh, no, I think I think I feel like we can probably just teach them as we go. Why are you a giant man now?
Yeah, it makes you sad
What your face is so funny
Who mari with her big body? I feel that's mean
I'm insecure
So, also by the way just as a fair warning if you open up a lot of drawers
A little monster will come up and like attack you
Okay, I'm not gonna do anything. Okay, I got the I got the key. I got it. Just follow
Wait, wait try try try wait wait try try
Thanks boy, you guys do have to catch up though. Like they
Do I have a big body or do I have like a hot sexy body?
You have a big body, but it is so hot and sexy.
But Shibi has a hot sexy body, how come I didn't get a big body?
Because we're little, so we don't get hot sexy, oh by the way, if you hide in the closet
for too long, a monster will start to kill you, so don't just go down the way.
So I'm literally just going to stand here then.
No, no, no, it's not tiny.
Let them learn as we play because it won't make any sense if you try to explain it before anything happens.
Okay, I think the key's in the next room.
What are we, what are we, what's our objective?
We just have to keep going through the doors essentially.
Yeah, we're trapped in a hotel.
The goal is just to get to the last door, that's all.
But it just gets harder and harder.
Yeah.
There's a lock on this one.
Wait, there's a fish on the wall.
Wait, guys, where'd you go?
Okay, I got scared.
We're looking for the key for the top of the door.
I am baby ducking so hard right now.
I'm having money.
It's okay, we'll protect you.
I don't believe that.
Wait, is anyone else getting a little bit dizzy?
I am getting a little bit motion sick doing all this.
Yeah, okay, if we die, we don't have to play this, we can play a different game.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't know, I didn't think that into it.
I didn't know either.
No, no, no, I was only starting the key.
I love being dizzy.
Oh.
That's a little weird.
Yeah, why is our people walking so tilty?
It's because it's like, if we're being, it's called immersion.
Oh, shit!
Look down, look down, look down, look down, look down, look down, look down.
Look down, look down, look down.
What am I looking down?
Six, because you're gonna die if you don't.
Okay.
Oh, can I look up?
Can I look up?
Yeah, can I look up now?
Wait, okay, there you guys are.
Where is she now?
I'm right behind you.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Cute girls doing horror things.
Can we need to go up the stairs?
No, no, no, no.
I'm sticking close to them.
Our next, our next door is seven.
So look for door seven.
Found it.
Seven.
I like the rain sounds.
I, I do too.
It's really well like made, made that.
I can't believe this is Roblox.
I have to rewatch that game theory video on doors.
Nine.
That was very good.
Oh, are we going in order?
Yeah, you have to.
There's a candle if anybody wants it.
What's it do?
It'll do.
This just gives you light.
Ten.
All right.
I'll hold on to it.
Okay.
Paintings.
Oh, yeah.
So wait, can I give a little debrief?
Maybe like a video?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I'll stop doing that.
So there you go.
So basically in this game,
you just want to keep going to the next door.
Like they're counting up,
but the farther that you go,
the harder it is to get through.
So there's going to be like puzzles and monsters
and like little like tasks that you have to do
to like be able to get through.
Oh, okay.
And yeah.
What's this one?
Is it happy with the paintings?
Yeah.
So that's what's here.
It's like, oh, you have to place the paintings
to match the shape behind it.
Oh, I want to see it.
The green border around the border.
Oh.
Tongue, tongue, tongue.
And then if you see a locked door,
you want to like search for a key
within the other.
I found a key.
Yeah, it'll come.
Good job.
You did it.
I'm super, oh, this is scary.
I don't like this big open.
Oh, what?
What?
Illuminal space.
But it's.
No, no, no, get out of the closet.
It's not time yet.
I was opening it
because I thought I could look inside,
but it just put me in there.
Wait.
OK.
Go in the closet.
I can't.
I don't think so.
I stole the closet from Chai.
I stole the closet from you.
OK, now you can get out.
It's about to happen.
Sorry, guys.
Motherfucking.
I apologize.
I haven't been looking at chat as much.
I've been really so locked into Roblox.
I got hit by a bug.
OK, you can get out the closet now.
No, the lights flickered.
I got scared.
I got worried.
Are we on 13 or 14?
Be careful not to go through the door.
You can hear the door.
Oh, no, you can't.
I missed the raid from you.
I feel bad.
When you play solo,
the door is grumble for you.
So sit.
OK, who wants it?
I already got hit by something.
So who wants to go?
What?
Open the door?
I can see you at this door.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, it's 14.
It's 14.
Oh, OK.
I mean, don't do it.
I just.
There's a cage.
I don't.
I don't want to be grabbed in the face.
I look for a lever.
It's OK.
I can look for it.
I look for the lever.
It's OK.
I'll do it for the preview.
I usually am a little bit more engaged, though.
So I still wanted to apologize.
I got it.
We can go back up sails now.
Yay.
The forest must be explored.
Where are the monsters?
I'm not scared.
Yeah, I am.
This one is more like a puzzling one.
Like, there's no little horror.
It'll come soon.
You keep saying that,
and it's making me anxious.
What is it?
I.
It'll come soon.
What is this?
Yeah, he was.
It's well designed,
and does it look good?
Oh, it's it's stressful.
I don't like that answer.
OK, that's 17.
OK, get in the closet.
Get in the closet.
I'm in a closet.
Everyone in?
Yep.
I'm making sure he's not coming.
Are they going to have to tear it up like this?
Yeah.
Oh, fuck, I'm dead.
Something's in front of me.
That was me.
OK, I died.
I'm going to come back though.
Wait, where do you find games?
I died, but I'll come back.
Get out the closet.
Now you're safe.
OK, I can't get out.
Oh, why?
If there's a door.
I'm coming.
How do I light it?
I don't like this.
Have you put a candle?
I'm going to be honest.
I have.
I spoke to you, so don't laugh.
How do I light the candle?
I'll keep you safe.
I don't know.
E.
Guys, am I ahead of you?
I'm pressing E.
I'm pressing one.
Yeah, press one and then click.
It's not letting me.
It says I can't.
Guys, what door are you on?
Maybe you need to have a.
I don't know.
We're at blood.
That's what you're at.
OK, I respond.
That's why we're at 17.
Oh, I'm at 19, I think.
We'll come back.
OK.
It's OK.
Guys, guys, this way.
It's because it's telling you where to go.
OK.
Wait, put my flashlight.
Awesome.
Come on.
Come this way.
Yeah, yeah.
You guys are silly.
Come on.
Wait.
I'm just screaming, scaring my cat.
I can't do nothing.
This way, this way.
Let's go together.
Is there a way to interrupt the game volume?
We are just never going to answer B ever.
What?
Everyone.
What did you say, shy?
Escape.
The game volume.
I just thought.
I'm just going to slow it by your head.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
OK, look down again.
Did you just pssst at me?
Come on, then.
I did it.
Look up.
Are you dead?
I'm not dead.
I'm almost dead.
Oh, God.
Did you hear the knock?
Yeah.
Yeah, guys, you can look up now, guys.
No, I don't think I want to.
I don't think I want to.
Look up.
It's OK.
It's dark.
I'm almost dead.
Where's Chai?
See me?
Keep looking for him.
Wait, where's Chai?
He's bringing my ear.
I don't like it.
Wait, I'm waiting for guys.
Wait for Chai.
Where's Chai?
I don't think guys went ahead without me.
Stevie, why are you trying to walk ahead?
I'm trying to find Chai.
Something keeps psssting at me.
Yeah, yeah, he does it a lot.
I'm dead.
Chibi, Chibi, why are you dead?
What happened?
I got pssst.
Are you got pissed?
I got pissed.
I got pissed too, because I didn't hear him.
And let's go, guys.
Alex, hold on.
Wait, can you respawn?
Or Chibi's gone forever and always?
Look for it and stare it down.
No, I'm afraid of eye contact.
Look down again.
And walk.
Just walk around him.
Oh, he's got all eyes.
He's literally all eyes.
That's fun.
I don't know how to do it.
How do I come back?
Oh, you have to buy it.
Okay, I'll just sit here.
Are you spectating?
Can you spectate?
I'm spectating.
Told mom.
Okay, I'll be.
I'm a big, great dog.
I'm living through.
I'm a big, brave dog.
I'm a big, brave, like, brave, like.
I'm alive.
I'm a pretty, brave, like, brave.
Can we go back to Drasztu and pray?
Can we go to, like,
Can we play a prank?
Can we do the bomb game?
Yeah, we can play past the bomb.
Get in the locket.
Yeah.
Can I just go try?
No, I think I accidentally did.
Okay, well, let's, the boys must be exploring.
No, I want to leave.
The dog, I thought the monkey was with us.
She's got so scared.
She's, she got that dog in her.
It's a banana, you know.
It's okay.
Well, he's got to get to the library,
and then we'll, then we'll be done.
Okay.
Try.
Hi, CB.
Oh, no, I'm being pissed.
She's looking at us.
Ready to carry us to victory.
Thank you, she's mine.
Look, now we're in the light.
How many doors are there?
That's up to 100.
I think there, yeah.
There's a lot, there's a lot to go through.
It's, it gets really intense.
Yeah, it's a lot to get hiding.
No, no.
Yes.
Okay, I have a lock pick.
Let's just go to the door.
Mario looks so funny.
I can't lie.
I know, it's really creepy.
Like a football player.
I feel like a football player.
I'm keeping everyone safe and sound.
Two of us have died.
Okay.
Well, that's not my fault that you died.
Technically it is.
Nuh-uh.
Little bit.
Daddy.
And O-T-P-O-G-O.
T-O.
You take me hot.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
So, uh, what do you, what do you mean this part?
He comes.
What do you mean he comes?
He approaches.
He comes.
You'll see him soon.
What are you?
What do I see?
A bunch of eyes.
Eyes coming.
I wish he wouldn't.
I hope we have protection.
He's gonna come.
Okay, so how good are you at direction?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Get him over for me!
How good are you at directions?
Like what kind of direction?
This is gonna be really emotional.
He's feeding my cat.
What?
Okay, good to know.
Let's go.
Yay!
He's coming for you.
He's having a little snack.
She's right.
Aye.
Aye, Tomah.
What is that?
Run.
Tomah, just run.
Just run and crouch.
Follow the blue eye, Tomah.
No!
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
What is with this awesome music?
I like Tomah.
I am so funny.
I had to see Tomah.
Oh, I know.
Are you start eating Tomah?
Oh my god, Tomah's dead.
I don't want to play.
Neither do I.
I'm good.
I don't play horror games.
You want to play five of the bomb?
Yeah, okay.
Okay, you guys want to play a nice one.
A nice one.
Okay, let me just die.
Let me just die.
I can't just leave.
Sorry.
The game and you won't allow it.
I'm not leaving.
Tomah, come here.
Tomah, I'm screaming.
I was just laughing.
I put so bad on the side.
Why are the lights flickering?
I'll die to this.
I don't want to.
What is that in the corner?
I left.
I don't want to know no more mystery.
I'll die to this.
I don't want to know no more.
I don't want to know no more mysteries, guys.
Do you want to play past the bomb now?
My instincts are too strong for this game.
Why am I scared of a Roblox game?
Get me out of here.
Because it's scary, Chibi.
The other one that I wanted to play was worse than this,
so now I know that we're not playing anymore.
What was the other one?
It's really bad.
It's really scary, actually.
It made me panic.
What's it called?
It's like a butcher game,
and I'm going to say,
do you want to play past the bomb or cake off?
What are you doing in cake off?
Is it actually cake off?
It's like dressed in prespo of cakes.
Yes, please, please, all under the cake line.
Let's do the cake.
And then we can do past the bomb.
No, we're not doing it.
Go away, go away, Harold.
Past the bomb, past the bomb.
Why don't you want to past the bomb with me?
I'm so sorry.
I'm just trying to snuggle with my cat and just recover.
I mean, I need to get a care bear.
Hold on.
Jesus Christ.
Well, you guys were so brave.
I'm so proud of you, though.
Yeah, we can do casual.
Are you doing me?
I thought this was a kids' game.
No.
Yeah, I thought this was a kids' game, too.
Oh, my God.
Just do that.
Okay, nice.
She, she, she surprises us with like another horror game.
It's actually not cake off.
No, I wouldn't do that.
That's me.
You guys actually sound scared and I feel kind of bad.
Oh, my heart.
I think it's because it's late and I had caffeine and my body is just.
And I'm drinking vodka.
Oh, you know.
We are going to cake.
Slash.
We're going to cake, ladies.
So cute.
Everything is happy.
Yeah, I see it.
Once you sense it, bountiful harvest of birthday party.
Once she used me like an ono hole before she buys me dinner.
Doesn't even offer me breakfast.
I'll offer you breakfast.
I can make you a breakfast.
I want like a traditional Dominican breakfast because I can make that for you.
That would be pretty good.
What's a traditional Dominican breakfast like?
Um, mango, salami, uh, yucca, uh, avocado and egg fried cheese.
Hmm.
Can I just have scrambled eggs with a little bit of salt and a little bit of pepper?
Yes.
Thank you.
You can totally scramble my eggs, by the way.
This is really cute.
Oh, fuck yeah.
Yeah.
I'm so excited.
I've never touched a woman before or I've been touched.
I'm going to do something a little bit different.
Actually, no.
We're just going to be basic.
Slide borders.
Wait, the game is loading.
It's taking forever.
I'm getting there.
Wait.
Let me try joining.
Oh, what?
Wait, I'm so confused.
Can I change the color?
H-O-T-O-O-G-O.
I can't spell.
Yeah.
Why not?
Words don't need to be spelled correct.
How do I age?
Ugh.
It's loading.
It's loading for me because I haven't played this before.
Oh.
Oh, this is so cute.
Oh, thank God.
I'm still thinking.
I still don't feel like I've recovered.
Guys, I'm sorry.
No, you're fine.
fine yeah you're fine we agree to it so like you know you're not liable or
nothing but like damn yeah let me find let me find my friends oh wait did I get
into a different game mode no I invited you no I know you're not lobby it just
making a birthday cake oh my birthday is this month she be remind remind
harem when your birthday is September 28 but again my bitch a present chat or
else you have a problem smacks your ass you let me listen to me chat yeah you
listen to her she's scarier than all of us get my woman a nice present better
make her special or else I'll come into your house and I'm busting your balls
get rid of stuff you ex out of it on the bottom
it didn't remove it I think it is it's kind of it's unlimited enough there a
while it'll be like guys by the way you can click on it if you click on
something you can't reset the top tier this is pissing me off you can take it
off it won't let me can I restart my game as a tutorial I feel what wait maybe
we should play this tutorial yeah you guys you guys skip the tutorial it kind of
voices it or real yeah it forces it on to you I don't know I'm I'm decorating a
birthday cake and I don't know do you like my birthday cake I'm decorating a
birthday I mean yeah I don't like you got but that's like pretty like a basic
one oh I heard you cuz really good that's the one that I heard they make
fries yeah yeah yeah I don't like fries are good I hate you got oh it's fucking
disgusting but yeah I want mine to make me a cake I'll make you a cake I'll make
chatted cake and then I'll put like my toes in the cake so then you can kind of
have like an extra little something and then when you taste it you're like wow
what's this extra flavor and I just smile at you
and you get scared because you think that I peed in it but no I just dip the
matter in a cake showing the cake you can pee in it while you're baking it
before you cook it oh this is just like modding in second life well we're there
I think okay chat to you I can't reset my looks like freaking trash because I
was clicking on accidentally click submit oh wait no it didn't work perfect reset
reset reset reset please I don't I think what you click on something I won't let
you change it so does mine yeah this is this is this is me and Chai making
she be into my cake so you can give it to you for your birthday that's really
sweet and wholesome I told you click on it at the bottom it's the bottom left
there's an X oh I didn't I don't know directions I'm sorry I think I said
bottom right I think I genuinely said bottom right I apologize yeah I was
staring at the bottom oh there is it is times yeah after a while it becomes time
all right chat let's explore the land of cake let's go upstairs wow that's the
little chair let's just sit down on beautiful oh my flipping god is an
obby I love obby's
look how good I am at the obby chat I'm gonna make my cake the gayest cake
huh I'm gonna make my cake the gayest cake
hey but what did you say Chai I was saying do you guys think my cake looks good
you guys I didn't see it I can't see cake yeah we can't see it yet I can't see
anybody else's cake not yet talking to your chat
you're talking to you either to you know I run Valentine what is a completely
different tune boys your children websites am I mumbling my mom falling you
know or a quiet that's fine it's turn you out I don't think it's
I don't think it's you
Drifty?
Those look like poop
That looks like just poop
She can't see what I'm saying to her
What is she saying?
Nothing
You mind your business, babe
You know, I like this, I'm submitting it
I'm almost done, mine
Wait, I feel like this could be really fun
If you knew how to do it properly
Me
There you are
I need to go up
Okay, I'm gonna submit
Come back, come back, come back
I'm submitting
Wait, wait, wait
Oh, blueberry
Oh, this is so cute
We're just running around
Alright, that's epic
Let's see this
Dear Maria
I've made, don't come over
I've made an absolutely dog shit cake
Absolute dog water
It's awful
I think your cake is beautiful
What is this?
Look in the middle
Oh my god
Whose Satan's cake is this in the middle?
I can't believe it
You guys like it, like cake?
That's yours?
I like it, I love it
Yeah
Ty, I'm gonna give two of them with diabetes
I don't know
Why is it so floating?
You know
They were really creative
What's your favorite idea?
Diabetes
I really hope mine wins
I didn't win
Wait, what? I voted
I voted for those two
Yeah, I voted for them
It's okay, it happens
I'm voting for this
I'm voting for the most unhinged ones now
That's just really scary
I feel like I'm even timidated to eat that cake
I like the purple box with a massive candle
Oh, I voted for the purple box
Purple box?
I voted for purple box, wait, no
No, yes I did
I really liked it
Oh my god, okay
Here's a close-up of my cake
And there's a close-up of my cake
Oh, that's yours, Tola
You actually yelled me out
That was pretty tasty
That was actually really cute
Mine was pretty basic
Chocolate heart cake
I didn't win
I feel like a five-year-old close
That they decorated it
I'm tired
It's okay, it's cute
Elders for a cake
Yay, there you go
I won't get you a cake
There's my cake on the side
I came in third
I came in second
I came in fifth
Okay, this one's actually kind of fun
This was fun
And it's not as stressful as
dressed to impress
I have Fia, Boomi, and Rena on my desk
at all at the same time
I was asked a week ago to make a list of games
and then we played one of the games
and then they all opted out from the horror
Well, we didn't know how scary Roblox
was actually going to be
I was like, oh, horror?
I thought it was going to be funny
No, I was picking genuine
I was going to...
The next one was worse
I was going to pick another one
There's so many micro-transactions in this game
Yeah, I don't know what's happening
Hey, look at my cake
It looks so cute
Hi, Chibi
Chibi
Wait, I'm tired
I'm washing
I'm getting a crate
I got a new treat
Oh, look, I'm in my cake
You can eat me
I would like to eat you
Where'd you eat my cake?
Wow
Chibi actually just dumped everything
that she clicked on here as well
I can't get out
I'm stuck
Wait, I want a picture of my cake
Guys, it's fucking gojo
Gojo's in the game
Hey, little gals, we are not all gay
It's okay, I'll make it even better
Summer sky
Although, purple pearls
Now I have vanilla sprinkles
I picked vanilla sprinkles
The theme is vanilla sprinkles
Boomi, what are you doing here?
Wait, I'm tired
Chibi is a scientist
Okay, this time I win
Oh, that's VIP
This is so cute
Boomi is sitting on my hand
Now I know how to play, for real
Yes
Everything else is locked
Wait
Ooh, that actually looks pretty good
I
I haven't heard that song
in forever
Okay
But how do you know that song?
I don't know
Yeah, that's fluffal puff
I don't know what that is
You literally just described her
I don't know what you mean
You don't know what that is
I'm kind of maybe stupid
I apologize
Kind of maybe
I know, that was out of line
My bad
But
It'd be like that sometimes
I know, because I'm also kind of stupid
Sometimes the stupidest girls are
The sweetest ladies
The dumber she is
The sweeter she is
I think I don't know
Maybe, I don't know about that one
But, you know, we'll believe it
Oh my god, I can literally
Make things like fly away
What the hell
That's how I discovered it
Yeah, what the heck
Dad, do you like my cake?
Do you like this cake?
Are these biscotties?
The fuck?
They are, they're biscotties
Oh, this is
This feels great
I love this
Oh, I got cookies
I can change the color of them
Okay
Wait, bows
Oh
Blackish
White
Sprinkles
Now
I got new tier 2 of my cake
Element as well
I don't like actual sprinkles
I think, which kind of sucks
Yeah
I want it to be yellow
A piss cake, I see
Yeah
Wait, wait, this is a trivial
My user name Otaku Vanilla
This is like for me
For real
It's just like me for real
Oh, this is so cute
There are sprinkles
You will
That's reassuring
I think?
Honestly, I'm not quite sure
It says sprinkles
Reyna, what are you doing?
She's like digging in my chair
Scran, what's a scran?
What's a scran?
I learned to screw them once
What?
Right now?
No, like a while ago
Talking about
Screwed them
I think we made a screwed them
Pack together, I don't know
What is a screwed them pack?
I don't know, I didn't want to ask anymore
What does that mean?
I don't know, that's what they did
They made a screwed them pack in my server
Oh, screwed them
Oh, that's okay
They made like a pack
You can't judge them
You can't absolutely judge them
You guys don't like my cake?
My audience doesn't like my cake
Kill them
I might
You can say for food, which in the context
Would you eat the food or not?
It's a scran
Oh, so you won't eat my cake
Because you hate me, you want me to die
Got it, I understand
I feel like, no
Queen, you're so sexy
Don't die
You're right, they should die
Queen, don't listen to them
They don't know
Where does Sprinkle's at?
Yeah, where are they?
I think it was because I clicked something that was cannoli related
Wait, someone said they must be pretty tight
For a screwed them pack
A screwed them pack is like a thing for real
Well, I think
It's not a sand castle, it's vanilla
Maybe a screwed them pack is like
Just a promising to dock each other
Or
Like froth or something like that
Okay, I'm gonna ask a question
What is froth and docking?
Well docking is when you
Make the penis heads kiss
And frothing is when you rub the penises together
What are we talking about?
I'm just sad, I wish that
Mari never asked
I'm sorry
I wish I never asked
Well, you asked
Yeah, I'm thinking about
You literally asked
I know, and now I'm thinking about
Them and thinking about it too
Guys, if I can't find the sprinkles, what's the point?
Yeah, I don't get it
Are we supposed to make our own?
I kind of made my own
I made
I improvised
Yeah, I don't know what a vanilla sprinkle cake looks like
I wonder if I'll run into Gojo in here
Well, you guys are
Oh, you can sit in the chairs
Yeah
Let me know if you see Gojo
Oh my god, I have 57 seconds
What?
Oh, 54
I'm sorry
I kind of literally made some
A little bird stuff in my chest
I thought
It actually looks good
It actually looks good today
This time I tried
Me too
That's all we can ask
Yeah, I didn't know what to do either
I'm sorry
It's kind of confusing
It's a vanilla cake
There's no sprinkle though
Vanilla
Oh
What?
I like my cake
I'm very happy
Okay, you want me to do the countdown?
Yeah
Wait, all these cakes are so beauty
I love them
These are cute
I like this one
I like how chill this is
You don't have to run around
You just have to click through menus
I don't think I'm going to make it, bros
I don't think I'm going to
I'm really sad
I worked really hard on that
It looked really good
Whenever your cake was, I bet it was beautiful
Mine was the one to the right
I voted for it
I'm really bummed
I think I voted for it
Don't cry
You know what?
The blue one kind of reminds me of Icy a bit
Icy snow paws
Yeah, it's like an Icy
Icy snow jobs
Icy snow paws
We could make our own themes if we wanted
We could be like
Let's all do a Touma cake
Let's all do a Shibi cake
Let's all do a Mari cake
And then try to theme it with the colors
Color schemes and everything
Shibi cake
You know what? I'm not even mad
I love your Shibi
Mine was the tall three tier one
I liked yours
I like
I like the one with color on it
It just really ups
That one has sprinkles
Yeah, how do they do that?
How do they do that?
I'm going to type in chat
How did you do that?
Oh my god, it's a black lady
Mari
I came in second
You were the blue one
We're even sitting on my cake
What the fuck?
You want me to hit them?
Yeah, we're going to hit you with a stick
Not a stick
I'm going to grab a pipe bomb and I'm going to put up your butts
Each and every single one of you individually
You can't say that
For fun, in game, in Minecraft
Oh wait
That was Gojo's cake
Gojo's really tried
I think
Mari?
Your model is freaking out
Why does my model always do that?
Oh god, it's Gojo
Look how big he is
I'm kind of scared
He's so tall
I'm going to run away
He's saying
Nah, I win
We have matching things
Nah, I'm Sigma
Wait, I can just do this to you
I can't line up to the
Microphone
Where are you?
There we go
I keep doing the gritty
For some reason
Yay
Big fan
Big fan, it's Kalyu Cheese
It's Kalyu Cheese
Oh my god, have you guys
Been seeing clips of that game that looks like
It's kind of like
Space Station 13 and Among Us
Oh
No, I have it
I don't even know what to vote for
I'll do Fruit Salad with Toma
Wait, okay
Or you can do Cocoa Kiss
That's fine, I'll go
Nah, we'll do Fruit Salad
Yummy, I'm getting lost
I literally did Fruit Salad and I did Cocoa Kiss
I wanted Cocoa Kiss
I changed it
Wait, I don't know what Cocoa is
You know what Cocoa is
Yes, I know
It's a nut
I'll do this one
A Cocoa Nut
Yeah, I have Cocoa Nuts
They're small though
My Cocoa Nuts are big
I have the audacity
I have a new plate
Can I
Can we share some Cocoa Nuts?
Yeah, we can share some Cocoa Nuts
I have nothing
Oh
Why is this in there?
I decorate my cake from the bottom up, okay guys
Okay
I like the top
Cocoa
You know what?
Can I say something controversial?
Yes
Raspberries are a trash fruit
They're so pretty but they taste so bad
when you get them fresh
I love raspberries
Raspberries? No way, you just said that
Raspberries hurt
Yep
I know
That's why I said
Can I say something controversial?
Extremely controversial
Can I say something?
I've never
I've never had a raspberry
That's weird
Listen, a lot of things freak me out
Is it because of the color?
Yeah
The recess? Probably
Wait, the color of raspberries
is red, so what does that even mean?
Um
I like you Chai
Okay
I like Chai though
Chai is my favorite red thing
My favorite red thing
Hey, Chibi, aren't you
You're my favorite mommy
There's a difference, okay?
Chai is like
We're in the same little itch brand category
You know, we're just a little bunch of babies
You're my favorite mommy red thing
See?
Wow, I see
What? You're my favorite
I give you my money, I don't want getting anybody my money
And you're being rude about it
You gave me your money? What do you mean you gave me your money?
I subbed to you
Oh yeah, that's true
Not once, but twice
And in your whole life I subbed to you
I don't know guys
I feel like that's emotional manipulation
Nuh-uh, nuh-uh, nuh-uh
It's my penis to be erect, so it's fine
What?
Who said that?
You did
It's weird, do you guys ever think about that?
What?
I'm not weird, I'm not weird
I'm not weird, right?
I'm not weird, guys
I would try to become a savage
I'm not weird
I don't know guys
I'm feeling real unsafe right now
What do you mean?
Like, we're supposed to be playing
a really fun, you know
case-mic rating game
I'm not, I'm not weird
This all started because of your
controversial opinion
All I said was I don't think
raspberries are good
I just got it, and I just got called weird
I know
And I just got called weird
I'm not weird, I'm just
It's uh, it's uh
It's just
my superpower, okay?
Chat, pick the color
Guys, I don't know what the fuck this cake
Wait, my cake doesn't have a
top, it's just one
thing
Your cake is naked
What cake?
You guys ever seen Max and Ruby?
I'm a little red
Yes, I love Max and Ruby
I always think that Ruby is a little
out of line though
Cause she's kind of
fucking bossy, and like
I don't think Max deserves that
I know, Max can't really think about it
cause he can't talk
A thing that like, he couldn't talk cause he like
Is he just not verbal?
Is that the thing? Yeah, cause his like
parents died or something
What? Oh wait, was there real lord
of it?
I don't know about all that
GV, but I just know that
Ruby can suck a
dick cause she's rude as hell
Max and Ruby
Max makes like a
dirt cake
Yeah
Chocolatey dirt cake
I wish I could
recreate that right now
I don't know what I'm
supposed to be doing
We're making a cocoa kiss
You know, just kiss the
I forgot the kiss part
Mwah
Where it is
Girls kissing on stream
Mwah
I like kissing on stream
I like kissing
Coco
Coco, okay
This is so peaceful, but I feel like
I don't like it because it's so peaceful
In my little
Dude, I have like a little toddler brain
I actually need to like be stimulated right now
Like I need someone to hold on to my face
Hold on
Oh there you go
Thank you
There you go, I got you
Wait, does that actually sound really fun?
Like a kiss?
No
I want them
Looks like little poops
I want
The keys, ma'am
We might need to put on
We might need to put on fruit sensory videos
For her, she's gonna go far with we go
I will fall asleep if we do that
I need you
You can fall asleep to those
They're a little too overstimulating for me
No, I like them
Wait, Ty, can I look at your cake?
I like pimple popping videos
Oh, I love those shoes
My cake looks like a guy jizzed all over it
I don't know what the flip I'm doing
White cream on it and stripping everywhere
I thought I was supposed to be Coco Kiss
Not Coco Piss
I don't know what I'm doing
You mean Coco Jizz
That was a good one
I think she's fading, guys
I think the man's fading
I've long faded
We should play past the ball
I'm so eepy
No, you can't be eepy
It's past my bedtime
I hate grandma so much
What?
You hate grandmas?
I love grandmas, they have the big heavy knockers
That's why you like grandmas
Not for the cookies and hugs
Like a MILF is fine
But a G MILF has experience
That's like two rounds of children to take care of
It's like a poop everywhere
We'll be a lord
ever having a jilf
I hope so
I'm already the jilf, did you guys see what I was wearing the other day?
I mean if they had a jilf
She could give gum gum
Oh yeah, you wear the jilf, I saw
Guys chat
I don't like my cake
Is it a gilf or a jilf?
Is it a gif or a jif?
I'm gilfin' off
What's up here?
I don't like mine either
I just submitted it because I was tired of looking at it
Ooh, a compiler
Really?
Ooh, I'll join you in platforming
I can't really jump
Oh god, I'm stuck under the cookie
I don't know what to do
I submitted my cake early because
I was proud of it
This is such better platforming
Okay chat
Also, also
I have to ask
Are you guys gonna go see Sonic 3?
I am, I am, I am
I have the Sonic movies
Go watch them together
They are good
We can say jilf
We can say jilf because it's like jif, right?
No
Jilf like jif
Oh these are good
There's so many cute cakes
I have to fart
Fart really bad, sorry
Just let it out
I'm scared
I like that one
This is hard
Kinda like this one on the end
These are really well done
This is a fun game
I wish I could rotate the camera
I wish I could pick all the cakes
That's the kiss right there
This is literally the meme of
Oh boy, two cakes
I love cake
Actually now I don't, I just
I'm a brownie person
I love brownies
Especially the corners
I prefer brownies over cake
Yeah, I like that
Oh, you guys can see
You guys
I'm excited
Do you guys put the video on ice cream?
Wait did everyone make it through?
Yes
Yay
I'd say confidently, not really knowing
This one's gonna win
We all know that
Which one, the light pink one?
Yeah
I really like the light pink one
It makes me feel like I'm kiss kiss fall in love
You know
I love that I could just
Automatically just set y'all off
I know kind of like
I know kind of the guitar part
But that's as far as I can like know it
You can play the guitar
Kind of, not really kind of
Sort of, and the piano
And the recorder
And the whistle flute
And the drums
Maybe it's because like
We put a little bit of red in yours
Like period blood
Well I mean
Well you know if you put period blood
In someone's food
That's like a love spell
In finding them for you
Yeah
Holy shit
How did the pink one not
Move forward
I don't like that
I don't know how I'm making it
I just really like
Is it me and Tova?
Yes, no
I really really really like
The one with the little
Poo Poo like on the table
You like my Poo Poo's on the table
Yeah I really like your Poo Poo's
On the table
You win!
Well
Time and frame on a good note
Good job TV
You did such a good job
Oh my god
I can't, the pink one should have won
What the hell?
Yeah right? It's so kiss kiss fall in love
Indeed, I can't
I hate gojo
Gojo
What does this thing say?
Nah, I'd win
Nah, I'm sigma
I feel like we need to have like a battle
Why is he playing cake?
Oh no
You know what's awful?
I think we're all dick sucking height to him
No!
Why would you say that?
I'm running away
Don't run away
It's true though
I don't want to be near him
I'm elbow height
I'm not closer to him
Why would I be like this?
I don't want to decorate
I want a platform
Let me platform
I think I'm going to tap out
I'm so tired
I will have to as well
I really think we should play again
I want to play more dress to impress
I'm not going to tap out
I'm playing roblox and now I'm like wide awake
I'm so easy
Maybe you can play with gojo
I'm going to play patch the bar
Because he is going to play it
I'm probably going to do
a drunk
A drunk
You're just going to do a drunk?
Okay, that was good
I've been drinking my vodka
So you know, I'm probably going to just
crossfade and like watch cartoons
It's fine
That's a nice idea
I hope you have lots of fun
I will
It's going to be awesome
So is everyone
ending and leaving?
Oh no
Okay, well then thank you for playing
I'm sorry if I was being really loud
I know
Oh shit, then should I not be playing this next round?
I am going to leave this game
so that I don't
I'm going to be playing patch the bomb
so loud
But I had fun, thank you for agreeing
to such a late time
for my sake
Yeah, of course
Need a lot to me
Thank you so much for it
We got to do this again
This was a great time
Thank you for having us
Thank you CB for putting us all together
Yeah
Good night
Good night CB
Good night Char
Good night Mari
Good night
I'm so tired
Hello
Hi
I'm so tired
Thank you guys
for hanging out
Hello
If you're a raider, if you're still here
Thank you
I'm sorry I didn't see you guys at first
But I hope you guys
had a good time
I had a good time
It was fun, I want to play more
to impress, my spongebob was very good
I'm surprised I got
as many wins as I did
Ending on a high note
Yeah
I'm sorry
We kept talking over each other
I couldn't hear Chai
after the time
I feel so bad
Fia is asleep
Reina is asleep next to me
I don't know where Boomi went
I don't know
Fia just woke up
Hi Fia
Thank you for being in the world
Hi
You're so wiggly
Fia
Thank you for being in the world
Hi
You're so wiggly
You're asking for a big stretch
Big stretch
Big stretch for you
Almost called me
my own name
It's okay
I'm a
girl fell asleep
now
The apiest warrior
You're not annoying
You're fine
Don't worry about it
I wish that I was more awake
because I felt like I would have been
a little bit more entertaining
to everybody
I was a little bit low energy
because it was a later stream
It might be the same
tomorrow because I think I have another later stream
No, wait, no, that's next week
I have two collabs
in one day and I'm like
Oh my god, why did I do that
but I wasn't paying attention
And I have FOMO
so I don't want to miss out on stuff
Yeah, tomorrow's ASMR
I'm just
It's been a tough
day for me today
because I don't feel good
My period is freaking
killing me, man
And I'm super tired
I've been like often on sleeping
I don't know why I'm so exhausted
I saw my parents today
I kind of just hung out at my parent's house
after I watered the long
and
I kind of just hung out
outside and just like touch grass
and just
I had breakfast outside
and then I was there for a couple hours
just like hanging out
and then my parents came home
and they're like, what are you doing here still
and I'm like, sorry, I just
wanted to be outside and your house is cleaner than mine
but
my mom gave me a sweatshirt
and it's so comfy
and I'm so happy
And yeah, it was nice
being around like plants and stuff
It's good to go outside
I wish a light flow
for a bath outside
Thank you
I hope that
it seems like you guys like the artwork
I posted today
I'm really glad
that you guys like it
and maybe I would
it seems like
I do miss being small
so maybe I would consider
something in the distant future
after like my 2.0 or something
like maybe like at least a little
cheapy model or whatever
getting that art was like
the highlight of my day
it was so cute
make us
so talented
they all just give her an idea
and she's just like boom
and I'm like, oh my god queen
yeah, pretty peak
would get pranked
by
yeah, it was so good
the queen
well like
yeah, I'm kind of bummed because
I did order the
design from somebody else
that's supposed to be like
Gyaru
school girl
cheapy
but I still haven't gotten any word back
and it should have been started
a bit ago so hopefully
actually let me see
I said they would
update me
they didn't respond to me
for a couple days and then
let's see did they respond
that would be so cool if they did
with the draft
they did not
we'll see
how that goes
my new mouse
my new mouse is here
and I'm actually using it right now
it's very good, it's so light
it's ridiculous how light it is
when I first took it out it literally feels like
I'm holding a piece of plastic
but it's not like it doesn't
feel cheap
I don't know how to explain it
yeah, it's already there
I already set it up in everything this morning
very satisfying click noise
madam is always on
yeah, it's really nice
thank you, thank you so much for the mouse
I appreciate you guys so much
yeah
tomorrow I'm gonna go
hang out with my parents
for a little bit
my parents know I can kind of
under the weather have a feeling good
so my parents are getting me Haitian food
which is nice
because I've been craving Haitian food
and then
I'm gonna hang out for
a couple hours and then
I think I have another
wait
I can't keep track of anything
yeah
and then I have
um
I was looking at the wrong week
and then I have
um
maybe I will come over later
because I said I would come over at like
two
and since my ASMR is at four
I'll go over at six instead
I'll text my parents
um
and so I can hang out with them
for a little bit while longer
just chill
and yeah
I still have to clean and stuff
I'm tired
yeah I'm spending time with family
home
my parents saw me today and my dad's like
you look tired and I'm like
shit
and this is before I knew I had my
period
um
yeah my parents are again very in tune
with my mental so they want to make sure
that I feel better and feel good
um
don't get me wrong like I was funny
in like in the group chat
with the girls I was like
guys I think I'm depressed
and then like I go to the bathroom
and then my parent comes and I'm like
I'm kidding it's PMS
I'm okay
cause I'm like
why do I feel like shit
I just feel like I just felt so weird
the past few days and I'm just like
oh my god that explains it
cause I'm like
isn't it seasonal effect disorder
like what's going on here
no it's just being a fucking woman
and having hormonal issues
um
do you track it
my uh it's very
irregular because of my
um birth control for my acne
um
and cause I uh
I like
genetically I like grow hair
like right under my chin
so it gets rid of that too
hahaha
I remember
when I first saw that I was like
what's happening to me
am I changing into a man
and my dad's like no
sorry you got the shit under the stick
some of you know your auntie
has like a full beard and I'm like
do our family just have secretly have
polycystic ovary syndrome and nobody knows
about it cause that's not a normal thing
gross
um I miss the beard
hahaha
I just like I just shave
like I'm just an intellect commercial
no it's never been that bad it's just like
it's just like thicker peach fuzz
um but it's it's it's gone
so it's cause it's medication
so thank god
um
like I know you guys like it when I'm like fuzzy
but like not like that
hahaha
um
um but yeah
this I hope
I'm sorry I feel really bad
I didn't give you guys more attention
and I'm sorry for my bad manners
to the raiders
cause I usually only get raided by my gen memes
so I'm probably gonna
DMEA and thank her for the raid
um
well I'll give you guys
attention lots of attention
tomorrow and when I say lots of attention
it means I'm
literally gonna scold you the entire time
in ASMR
I still have to think of more triggers
I think
I think I might do the same thing
I'll make it like a mukbang
and I eat a little bit
but also do like some degradation
and then um
I have to think of more
like some tapping stuff
yeah it was hard like I it was
like that's like the first time I had
like barely looked at chat
and I usually still pay attention to chat
and like read it so I can stay
like up to date with at least
what you guys are saying
but yeah I'm sorry
if I've been like a little bit goofy
the past few days now I literally know
why that is I like
don't know
I didn't know why
I was like feeling a little bit
off but it makes a
lot of sense I was locked in to dress to impress
that was so fun
I like when I whisper
repeat whisper triggers
hey why don't you guys
what triggers would you guys like
that would be relevant
I can love
trigger ideas
so
repeat
what other triggers would you guys like
it was okay I just
I just want to make sure
calling you stinky
stinky
do you get angry when that
happens
oh yeah I can
rage a little bit
I don't recall if I've been
particularly rage maybe
but the door dashing was a
couple days ago
sniffing the mic
sniffing
are you the one that's in my marrow
talking about smell stuff
I can tell you guys what I'm doing
for the October thing
for the I don't really mind
giving you a sneak peek
because I got you know I want you guys
to get your money's worth
I'll tell you guys the titles
and the tags
where's Google Drive
I haven't written them yet
because I was trying to make sure
what I can and can't do on
Patreon
no
no there's no
nah that's not allowed on Patreon
and you sent the thank you
rare aww
you're welcome
no google stick so the first
one is vampire wants
her fill
with a
job dumb sensual
smell play
and his slime girl
has you satisfied her curiosity
uh
Leonals
dumb
bondage
rough
bratty goblin girl
shows you who's boss
smalldom
a boobah
juba
edging, degradation
fourth one is you accidentally
the succubus and she demands to be
pleased and that's
a con du lingui
a foot
du job
dumb, sarcastic
demanding
but yeah
that's sort of
me sucky
yeah I was trying to think of like
aww I should do a duluhan one
but I kind of want
I feel like duluhan would kind of be
a little bit subby
um
uh
thank you
for the tip anonymous
you don't even say anything
you can leave me a note
thank you so much for the
the tip
I can't talk
Jesus
yeah
um
but yeah I
am like can I do blood play
and he's like
I bet you could
work around it
but I don't think I can
but I'm like more into vampire
and they're like uh
you could probably get away with it
so it might be a little bit of that
um
but yeah I'll be writing those out
but
I hope you guys
like them
um I wanted to ask
do you guys want my
banspeak voice for
uh
so like I might
do like
my normal speaking voice
for the goblin one
um
because like this is my normal speaking voice
uh
you want banspeak for goblin
with a little rasp
the goblin should be deeper
well the slime is like
higher pitch for the gullling
how did you come into my layer
it's only freaking like
like a
like oh
I had to think about
yeah like that
like tomboy
like
tomboy
okay
um
breathy
huh
another artist
did it like that and it was good
yeah breathy okay
so you think you're cool enough
to come and hang out with me huh
what happened
what would happen if I just
tucked you right in between
what would you do then huh
is there a script
you're most excited to release
I don't know
I haven't written them yet
and then the other ones
will be a little bit more sensual
um
or like deeper like my mommy
patreon voice
again
when I do do this voice it is mild
they put on so
oh pia just squeaked her sleep
it would be like the vampire
like I could do a really terrible
accent for the vamp
I wonder if I could do like a
a thread so that I didn't need an accent
I'll just speak normally
oh once brought you in
here
a new
morsel to play with
you're one of those weird ones
that likes to hang around vampires
for fun tucked you
well
you just smell so delicious
maybe a little like
well I think the accent would just come out bad so
a
British accent for the
yeah a British accent is a little bit easier
oh you smell
so delicious don't you
I could just
eat you up
or
I could
suck you dry
don't fight
you can't run away
yeah
man blood
alright British accent for the vampire
breathy breathy high pitched
voice for the goblin
so I really wanted to do like
hands on the desk here
I wanted to do like sarcastic
for the succubus
be like oh well you summoned me
what are you going to do about it
I suppose well
go ahead eat me out or whatever
that's the least you can do
just like kind of like sarcastic disinterest
does he guys like that
yeah
the sarcubus
and then
I don't know the voice for the slime
I think I just talk
you're interested in doing an audio bass
100% I would do an audio bass on that
Meryl that was a good one
got me all hot and bothered
bimbo slime
Fee are you okay
she's like squeaky in her sleep
she just dreams a little bit
a little ditzy yeah I was thinking
a little bit ditzy but like
but like demanding ditzy
like you know
you know how some people can be like dumb
but they like want you to do something
but they don't know what they're talking about
but they pretend they know what they're talking about
like
bit of an echo for the slime
yeah I think I would probably just
talk in this voice for the slime
slimes are slimy turns
that's a pretty cool thing
with the voice of the slime
well the slime is not going to take different forms
she's just going to be a slime
sounds pretty bang on for a slime
I am the slime
so
what do you got there
can you show me
no just
can't you just like put it in
why
are you resisting
wrap slimy hands around you
just do it
come on
don't be shy
that's a strange living
is going to slime girl
already have one here
slime she be
I wish I had time to get art made
for all of them
because I would totally do that
I did this thing I was talking to Marry
Marry was like oh you should try
like she will get like prepaid debit cards
to buy scab points and I tried that
it didn't work
so I'm pretty bummed
and people in Vigen just kind of work
like
I don't know
Vigen and Scab are just very
like Vigen
I don't really
there's a lot of westernized art styles
that I just I look
I don't really want a westernized art style
but
for scab they just take forever
so it's kind of annoying
slime be cotton slime
cotton bum
bum slime
a slime girl is my real self
can she be just be the entirety
of gen 4
I am the nun
I am the slime
I am the android
I am the
puppy play girl
I am just all of them
I am
I am the gen
I am the fourth gen
bring back the deep meme
um
Mrs. worldwide
puppy play but here I am as the puppy
well
if there was a puppy play person
I would want like
pet play like they would have to be sub
I realize none of us
are actually super subby
I just kind of
realize that because
it's
it's kind of weird like we're all
like very switches in video
there
like I don't really think
any of us are like
subby
because like everybody
yeah not by default
yeah we're all switcher
dom leaning which is very interesting because usually
like we be like
people are usually sub leaning
so uh
I bet for gen 2 we'll get like some super
subby girls and then like some really
hardcore dom a little bit harder than
like I know you guys
kind of want a harder
more aggressive dom
um
which I can be sometimes but I like
again
I want to be
able to help
strongy find people that
are more suited like I
want to be able to like
I hope
I honestly kind of want strongy to
in the um
questionnaire for like the
uh
the like the form that you fill out
like what your fetishes are
and like what your traits
are like what do you think
just so like you can find
personality traits
um there's a hard
yeah there's a higher dom
like I try my best
but I know I know it's not like
some people really expected
or wanted but I've already
come to terms with that and I think
a lot of people have too and just realize
that
I'm just
makes sense for streamer to be dom because streamer is
director of everything that happens
um
but like
honestly it's not
it's not hard being a sub on stream
either because like Amy's done it pretty
well with the whole like denial thing
but the thing is it's up to chat
for that stuff and sometimes chat
can kind of baby their sub
um
cause like I could just
totally right now be like oh
please please just let me
just let me splooge
that's all I want won't you please
I just want you to pound me
I don't deserve this I like
like um
uh
if
if I was
I would definitely um if I was
like cast as a sub
I would be very
riona
and like
beat the shit out of me like honestly
me and Amy are so much alike we were talking today
she's just I've been like
I talk to Amy a lot
speaking of what she literally messes me
she literally just messes me hello
that is really so funny
um
that's how you
heard you guys say hi
also
my
um
cause me and Amy have a lot of
stuff in common
um it was really cool I
like scrolled through
her apartment stream before
um
and I took a little break
from trying to clean
and I did I actually
when I say I cleaned I mean I
turned on the Roomba
and I picked up my house I need to wipe
stuff hi Mari
how do I raid don't raid me
please I'm literally going to end soon
um you have to click edit
then customization then redirect
and then it has to be someone to that
you're subscribed to
Mari I'm ending soon
I'm sorry I was just
kind of updating my channel and stuff
cause I didn't get to talk to them
why don't you
I thought you were going to keep playing let me
I was going to raid you actually am I
subscribed to you
anyway
I'm going to click like that five
times because that's what I am
there we go
leave me alone
I didn't know you're going to start
streaming on youtube
are you going to
Mari are you going to keep streaming
cause I'll raid you
right now what I was saying
I'm sleep talking right now
let me scroll up
oh yeah I was going to say
I was flipping I was scrolling through her
apartment thing and I saw her
um
I saw her alter and I'm like oh my god
that's so cool
we're really literally the only one that's like not
witchy is like Azura and scrawny
actually yeah I don't know if Azura is
but the rest of us were like
yeah
I don't have any of their links in the
are you serious
I
didn't have any of their links in the description
I'm actually going to
I thought I updated
I just put their names
oh
Mari
why didn't any of you guys tell me
that you probably did and I didn't
fucking see it
I literally say oh check out
their channels and there's
nothing there in the description
oh my god
I hate it here
Jesus Christ what's wrong with me
God watchers you'll see it
yeah
well check them out now
please you guys
you guys
alright
oh go to bed
Amy says hi
she said I hope you guys
enjoy dress to impress it was
really fun
so fun we gotta
play
together
maybe with Icy
I think Icy would be good at it
how the hell did Icy I don't think she saw it
I'm like yo what are you gonna hang out
cricket
probably because it's late and she's asleep
it's probably because
it's probably because it's not her time zone
but I just expect to be answered immediately
alright
well
I think it's time for me to go
to bed
I'm gonna raid
Mari
what the hell just happened
oh my god I have like 50 tabs
open of the same thing because I don't know
what I'm doing
eee
redirect add
sometimes I have to
literally close out and reopen stuff
because
sometimes when you just subscribe to someone they don't show up
like Mari's not showing up
so weird
oh it's because she has a freaking
whitelist on Mari are you still here
she's literally I can't raid her because she has
whitelist on
as Mari so I'll add you to their
live direct redirect list
I can't raid you
because you made it so that only
people that you approve of can raid you
what's that
Mari stop being privilege
how I turn it honestly I don't know
I'll be I'll actually be honest with you
you might have to you might have to
just don't know all that
you might have to google that because my channel
was set up with that just already
that setting just changed automatically
so I have no idea
it is 1am I am fading
fading slowly
I'm surprised I'm not
like jacked up out of my mind because I'm drinking
gamer subs I'm drinking titty milk right now
I feel like this I got a new cup
and it's so freaking cool looking
I forget which one it is I heard which one
it's called it has like
so much art on it and it has a really
cool shaker thingy
yeah
see I wasn't subscribed to her
she doesn't have me on her whitelist
we're both
we're both in trouble
my neck is not connected to my body
transparent slime bunny girl madem
what
can I turn my opacity down
I
am seeing if I can
if I do color correction
now I just look like a ghost
I'm done
harlot
you're so stinky harlot
spooky
spooky scary
skeletons
sentures
down your spine
I was going to cover a song
and I think it might be too hard for me
because I have a lot to do this month
I think I might add something to my plate
I shouldn't have
yeah
maybe I'll do a ghost ASMR
ASMR
maybe I'll do that the first week of October
come let the children
show you
away
into a
bundle
small thing
and magic
with all
my powers
don't take
me away
into a
bundle
shuttle
um
don't you want me to use this song
I am
saying that song for
my VNU audition
for the
spooky parade gym that they had
spooky carnival gym
do do do do do do
I'll take
me away
into
a
bundle
magic
with all my
powers
I don't know how many lyrics
but I love that movie
you guys think I can read bar
I highly doubt it
yeah I can
alright guys
have a good night
sleep tight
and don't let the
she be by
where you can
I prefer it if you want
but I hope you have
a good rest of your
evening
you stinky little
heart
do